polls have opened across a very divided
United Kingdom in a vote that more than
half the country never even wanted
European parliamentary elect elections
kicked off with the country engulfed and
in even more political turmoil over
breaks in the British prime minister
tourism is fighting for her job with
even some of her own cabinet ministers
revolting over her latest brexit
withdrawal plan last night a key Pro
brexit Minister unrealism resigned over
the revised deal saying it didn't
deliver Gregson
but Britain's leader is standing firm
and rejecting calls to stand down now
let's head straight to London to hear
from VW's bigoted mass bigot resume is
still refusing to budge as the country
votes in the European election where a
Conservative Party's projected to get a
meager 7 percent what does this mean for
her future
her future looks very very bleak for now
it looks like she's almost bunkered into
Downing Street maybe pushed the
furniture against the door from the
inside we know that many have asked her
to go many cabinet colleagues and it
seems like small matter of days than a
matter of week when she's going or at
least announcing her departure and of
course at a moment when really important
elections are taking place in the UK
European elections this is not a good
look for the Conservative Party who are
set out to take a big hit the both the
big parties are set out to take a big
hit in these European elections and
begin if the brakes a timetable had
worked to plan the country would not
have even been in the EU by now given
that how much interest is there in this
European election well this will be
interesting to see it could go either
way it could be that people are just
coming here and droves and just
expressing their opinion it is really
all about brexit or that they say well
there I'm just there to frustrated to to
just come we've talked to the people
here in this polling station where we
are in central London and they've said
that for now it's more like a trickle so
not really huge amount of people
storming
polling station to tell the politicians
what they think one party that we are
pretty sure it's going to benefit from
all this deadlock that we've seen over
brexit here in the UK is Nigel Farage's
new party it's called a brexit party
it's pretty much a one-man band and
nitro Faraj is promising the people that
actually everything is much easier than
the politicians in Westminster make out
who can't make up the mind the
conditions that they want to live in
here saying well let's just leave and
the deal with the European Union is not
very important and his message is
resonating with many voters I've been to
some of his rallies and let's see what
the mood is like there he's back
wherever Nigel Farage goes he's welcomed
like a star here in Wales for example
this message Theresa May has betrayed
the country she's unconditionally
accepted all of Brussels demands during
the withdrawal negotiations and it's not
her deal it's a document drafted by
Monsieur Barney a with Angela garage
suggests Britain doesn't need a deal
with Brussels the main thing is to leave
the EU he doesn't mention that would
probably cost jobs I'm afraid that there
is no chance of brexit being delivered
with our current two-party system and
our current government and we're gonna
have to fight for it again but I believe
we can do so I think I think the brexit
referendum acted rather like the sort of
a genie coming out of a bottle it's not
going back in the city of Peterborough
over a thousand people come to check out
the new party many of them used to vote
for the Conservatives the government
extra moment of time are liars deceiving
us and they are nothing but crook
surfers are concerned a treasonable
people people are very angry and feel
very hurt and upset that their vote is
being ignored and democracy is being
trampled all over
the party claims to have gained more
than a hundred thousand new members in
just a few weeks
Jane Duke hey can only dream of such
numbers rachel johnson is in the
spotlight in bath in southwest England
a political newcomer who has one main
goal we have to stop a Faraj takeover of
this country with all the lack of values
and all the lies that that campaigner
represents he's it's a one-man show it's
a vehicle to get him into Downing Street
he's taking the gartner country up the
garden path and over the cliff the new
romaine party chains UK has a clear
enemy Nigel Farage's brexit party but
the anti brexit vote is splintered and
that might be one reason why the pro
Europeans have not been able to attract
nearly the same crowds as a brexit party
in bath four rows of chairs are enough
to accommodate the crowd many of those
who have come are disappointed by the
establishment parties this is an
opportunity to see what a romaine party
a new voice a fresh voice has to say to
me and I was very impressed actually the
passion with which they spoke I'm a
passionate European and I believe
changing VK are one of the only parties
to really really support the people's
vote and to support Romania the big
parties are being punished in the EU
elections and it looks like the populist
will be the biggest winners so yes it
looks like Nigel Ferraris easy message
is really resonating with voters he
makes it easy to leave there to leave
the European Union whereas labour and
the conservative the traditional bigger
parties recognize the how how difficult
the actual process is and the MPs in
Parliament are really reluctant to leave
without a deal like Nigel Farage
suggests so make it a big surge for the
populist expected but what role of
British politicians likely to play in
the next EU Parliament
well they have to assume that they are
going to stay there we are facing
deadlock at the moment so in Parliament
we don't have a clear majority for any
cause of brexit we know that we are set
the UK is set to leave the European
Union at the end of October so if they
don't find a solution then the UK would
would leave without any deal but the
other way out would be to revoke article
50 so that is something that lawmakers
could contemplate and in that instance
the Mme peas that are elected now would
have to stay for a long time so they
would have to be prepared to stay for a
long time at least bigoted mass in
London thank you very much
you